( intro music )
( applause )
This first picture is really
my first understanding
of exploration and discovery.
As early as I can remember,
my mother would take me
on nature walks behind our house
in the south shore
of Massachusetts.
Each day, we would go
in the back of the woods
and at each step
there was discovery.
I can clearly
remember these days
of going under the
leaf litter and finding
lady slippers, or flowering
Indian peace pipes
or an old fox skull.
These days of discovery
have stayed with me.
This sense that the
forest was a place
of spiritual communion
has also stayed with me.
My mother's sense of awe
at each thing that we would
find that was extraordinary,
really was contagious
and it instilled in me
this lesson that I
carry with me today.
That the definition of
extraordinary is just that.
It's finding something ordinary,
but somehow elevated in meaning.
It started with really
this ephemeral bloom
of a lady slipper.
In the third grade, I was asked
to do a project on an animal
and as I flipped through
the encyclopedia of animals
I came across the
ring-tailed lemur.
I completely fell in love.
I told my family that I
was moving to Madagascar
and they all laughed at me.
( audience laughing )
But it really was then that I
began this life-long commitment
to a place that was
so far from home
but so close to my heart.
I did research for this project.
I went to our local
library and I came across
this National Geographic
issue from 1988.
I can remember
plopping myself down
on a bean bag chair and
reading through this issue,
"Lemurs on the edge
of survival".
It created in me this
sense of urgency,
this sense of passion,
this sense of purpose
that I needed to
go to Madagascar
and protect lemurs from
this very certain fate
of endangerment, of extinction.
A few years later,
in the same library,
I came across a book
called "The Aye-Aye and I"
written by Gerald Durrell.
I read through this voraciously.
It became my favorite book,
and in many ways it still is.
Gerald Durrell became my hero.
He was a naturalist
that was dedicated
to saving animals in peril.
He had a very special place
in his heart for Madagascar.
He is known as saying
"The world is as delicate
and as complicated
as a spider's web.
If you touch one
thread, you send shutters
running through all
of the other threads.
We are not just tearing
the web, we are really
tearing great holes in it."
I really began to
dedicate myself
to finding a way to
go to Madagascar.
I wanted to write
a letter to Gerald Durrell
and I sent him a letter
right after I read the book
and I told him how much
that book meant to me.
A few months later, I got
a letter back from his wife
telling me that
Jerry had passed.
That really propelled
me even more
to really start my
career and find a way
to get to Madagascar.
As you can tell from this story,
I did find my way to Madagascar.
I just met Lee Durrell,
his wife, last year there.
I have now spent
the last 15 years there.
First doing this carnivore
behavioral biology research,
then starting my own
environmental education
initiative
and before my senior
year in college,
I decided to be intrepid
and start off my own project
in the northeast of
Madagascar, where Jerry worked.
This is what I found.
This picture is
incredibly disturbing.
This picture still
haunts me to this day,
and yet I have come
to understand it.
This is a far cry from the
image that I had in my head
from reading Jerry's book,
and yet it was so
important for me
to really understand
what this image meant.
I did the first research
creating a systematic survey
of hunting in Madagascar.
That started 10 years ago.
We have now monitored
this population
for the past 10 years,
really looking at their
reliance on local wildlife.
It was the first
systematic survey.
Madagascar's paradigm
has always been
that the island was on fire
and that slash and burn
was destroying the forest
yet there was a
more hidden threat
crippling the wildlife
populations in Madagascar.
It was this undercover
threat of hunting.
No one had explored this before
and so I set out to do that.
In addition to the
wildlife surveys,
I initiated a kind of project
to look at a lot of
the lemur populations
and how hunting was occurring.
I just want to send a special
"thank you" to Jon Betz,
who is hopefully here.
He is a National
Geographic photographer
who came out to visit
me a few months ago
in Madagascar and the next
series of images are all his.
In addition to the
hunting surveys,
we set up ways of
training local Malagasy,
training Malagasy
university students
to monitor their own wildlife.
We did this in both diurnal
and nocturnal surveys.
We wanted to understand
the ways in which hunting,
and I was very
unidirectionally focused,
looking at how hunting
impacted
these wildlife
population dynamics,
and not just lemurs
but the tenrecs.
These are like little hedgehogs.
We set up a mark
and capture project
to look at population dynamics.
We attached radio
transmitters to their backs
to follow them and
understand their range
and understand the ways in
which their life history
was affected by hunting.
All of this wildlife, albeit
beautiful, exotic, extraordinary
was reduced by local
people to one thing:
food.
All of it was food.
As I spent year after
year in these communities
and as I learned all of
their local languages,
I came to realize that I needed
to look through the
forest in their eyes.
It all became clear to me.
These people weren't criminals,
although they were.
Most of the hunting in
Madagascar is illegal.
But these men were family men.
They were providers.
They were protecting
their family's welfare.
What I set out to do was
to start a research team.
Locally, we called
ourselves MAHERY
which means strength
in the Malagasy language.
It also is an acronym
that stands for
Madagascar's Health and
Environmental Research.
In 2008, our team did
a systematic survey
of how wildlife is connected
to human nutrition.
We found that when
the local communities
lost access to wildlife,
their rates of anemia
would actually
increase by 30 percent.
These results were astounding.
It really taught us
that if local people
messed with their
natural environment,
they were actually
self-depleting
their own nutritional resource.
It was this direct linkage
between environmental change
and human well-being.
It also taught me that if
you mess with mother nature,
she might stop taking care
of all of her children.
For the past 15 months,
what ended last month,
we decided to study this
phenomenon in earnest.
Through support from the
Rockefeller Foundation,
we enrolled 700
people into our study,
and on a daily basis
over these 15 months
we measured everything that
they were eating in their diet.
Every four months we
took a blood sample.
We took fecal samples,
fingernail samples,
so that we could understand
the ways in which
all of these things that
are coming from the forest
were providing nutritional
benefits to them.
From the fecal samples,
looking at the ways
in which intestinal
parasites affected nutrition.
How dietary intake
and pharmaceutical use
affected their microbiome.
I wanted to stop
having tunnel vision.
Stop looking at only the ways
in which humans were
affecting the environment
but also the ways in which
the environment circled back
and can benefit humans
to reframe the conversation
of conservation.
Not only were we looking at
nutrition and food security,
we were also looking
at a different dimension
of human and
wildlife interaction.
The ways in which
hunting wildlife
presented a disease risk.
So 75 percent of emerging
infectious diseases
are zoonotic, meaning
they are transferred
from animals to humans.
Everything like SARS
and avian influenza,
Ebola, HIV, all of
these major pandemics
are actually started
in animal hosts
and transferred to humans.
But the most interesting
thing that I learned
is really from local people.
The image behind me
is a local rendition
of the Kalanoro.
She is a part of their local
spiritual animist pantheon.
She is always envisioned
in the same way,
as a dwarf with long
hair and long fingernails
and backwards facing feet,
with her heel pointing forward
and her toes pointing backwards
so that when she walks, no
one can track and find her.
But she does appear
in people's dreams.
What she tells them
in those dreams
is which animals
to have a taboo for.
She can, in many ways, be
seen as a conservation spirit.
She is telling certain
people what to not eat,
what wildlife species
should be protected.
And yet what she really is
is a health spirit.
In those dreams,
she is giving messages
like "Don't eat this
particular type of wildlife
because your skin
will change color.
You'll bleed from your eyes,
You'll bleed from your
ears or you'll die."
All of these symptoms
are indicative
of zoonotic disease transfer.
I got very interested
to see whether or not
there was actually
a relationship between
this traditional
epidemiological knowledge
and what was actually there
as a present disease risk.
What I found through
surveying 1,200 households
over the past 10 years was
that the number one
most commonly tabooed
wildlife species was
the hedgehog tenrec.
More than 50 percent
of the population
had a taboo
for the hedgehog tenrec.
Although these stories
have been passed on
for generations, what
we found was that
just last year there
was a discovery
that the bubonic
plague is present
in the hedgehog tenrec
and that they have
this kind of immunity
to bubonic plague.
It consistently spills
over into human populations
and wildlife populations
and rodent populations
and presents a disease risk.
If you have been
following the news,
in October of last year,
Madagascar experienced
the largest epidemic outbreak
of bubonic plague
since the middle ages.
I just think there is
a tremendous amount
that we can learn
through local knowledge.
So what happens now?
We know for two reasons that
wildlife consumption is bad.
It presents this terrible risk
to endemic wildlife populations.
It presents a tremendous
infectious disease
risk to local humans,
and yet it provides
this critical
source of nutrition
to local people.
So where do we go?
We decided to implement
a sustainable chicken
husbandry project.
This is a good idea for
several different reasons.
Number one is that I have done
a taste preferences study
looking at 23 different
species of wildlife
and 10 species of
domesticated meats
and across the board,
chicken is their number
one taste preference.
So not everything
tastes like chicken.
( audience laughing )
The second is that
using this pervasive
and complex taboo
system across the board,
no one has
a taboo for chicken.
If we are looking
at a population intervention
that is applicable to everyone,
chicken is the answer.
Wildlife species
are less preferred
and also less expensive.
If we can develop ways to
make chickens more productive,
it can reduce the price
and almost naturally wean
people away from wildlife
and into chicken.
The problem is that
there is Newcastle Disease.
This is a pathogen that
wipes out 80 to 100 percent
of the chicken flock seasonally.
We just received funding
from the Nordic
Family Foundation
a few weeks ago, actually,
and it will import
a vaccine from Malaysia,
subsidize its costs.
We will get extension agents
that will be teaching people
about bio-security measures
and husbandry conditions
and hopefully be able to
really tackle the problem
on a local scale.
The case study
that I've mentioned
is not operating in isolation.
It's part of a larger
effort called HEAL,
Health and Ecosystems:
Analysis of Linkages.
It's a program
that's based at WCS.
I've recently
become the director,
as of January.
It's a 25 institution
consortium that partners
academic, NGO, and
governmental organizations
together to tackle
this data gap.
It's very intuitive
that the environment
and health is linked,
and yet the evidence
base is very weak.
What I see as a very
natural transfer
from the terrestrial system
into the marine system
to look at the ways in
which marine conservation
through no-take zones,
seasonal closures,
or gear restrictions
can protect biodiversity
but also increase the
productivity of fish docks.
This increased productivity
doesn't stay within the bounds
of the marine protected area,
but spills over into
adjacent communities.
We want to measure
empirically the ways in which
there are nutritional benefits,
livelihood benefits,
health benefits,
that arise from
marine conservation
so we don't think of it
as an environmental
intervention.
We can frame conservation
as a public health intervention.
In closing, I just
want to say
that I really found
this extraordinary place
in Madagascar,
but I also found it
in my back yard.
The more and more
I discover about myself,
the more and more I see
that these experiences
were entirely parallel.
That as I began to look
through local people's eyes
and see how they
really saw the forest
as benefiting their health,
we, too, are receiving
a very certain type
of health benefit from the
areas that surround us.
I just want to say
that exploration
can really take us far afield,
and yet I think the most
important thing that we can do
is take what we find
in those explorations
and make sure that
we take it home.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )